erase the image of zoe kravitz is
turning a lot of heads and this one is
totally Zoe can we talk about how the
Rolling Stone cover first I was really
excited to recreate my mom's cover it
was excited to do it what did she think
she loves it
Zoe now joins Eddie Redmayne and Johnny
Depp for the JK Rowling sequel fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald we
never met a monster who couldn't love a
stinker
there's no better place to talk about
the franchise's epic return than
Universal Studios Wizarding World of
Harry Potter it's kind of like British
British weather but with the sunshine so
you don't snow everywhere but it's
actually really warm and toasty Eddy's
noot meets Jude Law as the younger Albus
Dumbledore it's smart because you know
you remember it there's this wonderful
terminal Wizarding World and of course
the Potter films and these films do join
up and since you can't be a wizard
without a wine Keltie got the cast to
give her a little spell casting tutorial
there you go this is good but you're not
my team anyway see that is yeah now feel
his dinky little thing it's like oh yeah
there you go quick one I think that
might have been the best moment of my
life
wave that magic wand and get folks in
the theaters because fantastic beasts
the crimes of Grindelwald opens the
fifth Friday
[Music]
[Applause]